foreign
we got Tabitha in Atlanta GA what's
going on Tabitha
hi there
um first of all I am very excited that I
even get to speak with you guys
um so um I have several questions
um
um basically okay so I'm a I'm recovery
I'm a recovering addict so I'm sick I'm
sorry I'm a little nervous that's okay
we're doing great Tabitha we're here for
you we're with you we're gonna hold your
hand and get you through this
sorry
I now work as a certified peer
specialist and a case manager for the
Georgia adult drug court
um so this is what's going on I am
um never I was born in poverty and
basically my parents were addicts
themselves so I would never taught any
of these things until I just recently
we started watching these YouTube videos
and it's like a light bulb in my head I
have a I have a career I do not have any
college education
um I'm living from check to check I live
in a um a home for women and children
and so I'm a single mother and I live in
a home where I only pay 30 of my income
a month so I pay 700 in rent okay a
month for where I'm staying um I'm but I
am I living from check to check I owe a
four thousand dollars to Aspen Dental
because without education and the
research I just ran to the first place
to get my teeth fixed okay
um so the only debt I have is the forty
five hundred dollars I'm 39 years old
um
and I want to be successful and I want
to be successful with my money and I
want to break the chain of property for
me and my son so he can have a great
life and I don't know where to begin
well first of all you're already
breaking that chain six years clean the
fact that you're diving in you're
looking at YouTube videos you're calling
into the show you are breaking that
chain I know I speak for myself and
George when I say we are so proud of you
um thank you very very I'm inspired by
your story already and when we talk
about changing your family tree this is
it and I cannot think of a more noble
and strong why than the one that you
have today and that's what gives me hope
that you are going to get to where you
want to get financially and we can
definitely help you get there
so what's your income what's your income
looking like
okay so my annual income is um thirty
four thousand and how much do you see
every month in your check
so every month of my check
um one the two thousand
uh two three I see about uh 2300 okay
2300 and you've got your rent going out
and then you've got this Dental uh
situation you said you're a single mom
how many kids do you have
I have one one child how old
he is six years old I'm very very cool
he's going on 36. wow so that really was
your why six years old six years clean
very very cool okay so what are your
other expenses do you have fixed
expenses where you're renting right now
because I'm I'm seeing there's 1600
bucks left you still got to put food on
the table you got to cover some other
bills so you're saying I'm paycheck to
paycheck what do you think is the cause
of that right now
I'm gonna tell you about
the cup right here and I started
I started Center and everything like
that when I say I was never really
taught
how to money is the tool that you use
it's not to just spin spin and when I
was going to Macy's to to catch up with
the Joneses I was getting perfumes high
heels outfits I decorated my my
apartment because I thought this is what
you do you decorate and you make
everything look great
so you're saying that you were just kind
of spinning like crazy and I'm guessing
that you're ready to stop doing that
absolutely okay so what I would do and
we're gonna set you up with every dollar
are you already on every dollar
um no okay so every dollar is our
budgeting platform here at Ramsay it is
the best and easiest budgeting tool
that's out there and I can say that from
personal experience we're going to set
you up with that
um don't get off the call until you get
that from our phone screener and um more
than that I also want you to sign up for
a webinar that I'm hosting next week on
budgeting we're going to walk through
all of that together it's free so we'll
also make sure you have the information
for that and in the meantime like like
George said you've got this great margin
here obviously I'd like to see even more
margin is there something that you can
do to increase your income
CA would be amazing if I could go get a
second job
um the only problem I have with that is
finding someone to watch my little boy
at night and see luckily I have
um you know school during the day I work
the nine to five hours so it works out
perfectly
um but that would be
well there's no child care provided
through your housing right now
oh no okay absolutely not it's like it's
definitely Independent Living yeah with
your skill set could you get another job
that would pay more in the same kind of
field or same role
okay and that that's what the school is
for
um the school well writing that I don't
have no schooling right now oh okay okay
sorry when you said you were at school
during the day my mind kind of went in a
different direction so my son is at
school during the day so that's why
these hours they fit perfectly but um
I'm also at this point maybe if I were
to go get that second job
um
I could make it happen yeah so you're
you're A1 and A2 here are we're getting
on a budget which is we're listing out
those expenses you know what you've got
to pay for right the 700 in rent food
utilities Transportation all of those
four walls you've got to do
um and then anything extra if you have
extra we're hitting it at this debt and
in the meantime we're looking on
opportunities to get your income up long
term and in the meantime even some
short-term uh opportunities to get that
income up how does that sound
it sounds amazing you're amazing it
sounds so it's like it's it's like a
light bulb that has been over my head
for the past week and a half I've been
walking around like some of my friends
think I'm crazy and everything I'm like
I've got a plan now come on man you know
it's a good sign if people are making
fun of your financial plan you're going
in the right direction I know that's
right you are going to inspire so many
people people who have been where you've
been people who want to be where you're
going to be and I can't wait for you to
call back and share your debt-free store
you're gonna be there in no time 4 500
bucks feels like a mountain right now
you're gonna look back at that when you
have a fully funded emergency fund no
debt saving for the future going I did
that